excusez moi madame je crois que vos
affaires sont sur mon siège pardon
or c'est une blague au nom il manquait
plus que ça vous avez compris ce que
j'ai dit tu fait le coup du touriste
italien encore maintenant s'il vous
plaît madame il faut que je change de
place je suis désolé l'avion est complet
on a été marié 12,9 au nez les pires de
ma vie on a été mariée que cinq ans oui
plus le temps de m'en remettre ce siège
c'est non je regrette je ne peux rien
faire
je vous ai de ma place babel tâchez de
vous au rap et si jamais on s'écrase
vous me [ __ ] et ça je suis dit que
j'allais la chercher dans quatre jours
entre viva et faisait un gars qu'elle
connaît à peine à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez excuse moi le milieu
de ma phrase a interrompu le début de la
tienne du shop années de sylvie t mais
c'est la bouteille merci
pour qu'on ait une stratégie même si
c'est pénible pour nous deux il faut
qu'on fasse une trêve pour que sa poche
on va faire équipe pas de méchant cela
de dispute on doit parler d'une seule
bruit je valide on commencera dès qu'on
aura vu lille
on lui dit que mariage est annulé et on
la ramène à la maison mais tu sais bien
que quand on dit à lily ne fait pas
salle comprend contraire je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit présent pour elle à 100%
on lui montre qu'on la soutient qu'on
l'ait mais subtilement on la pousse à
l'art dé monsieur al qui est intéressant
moi je pensais plutôt un genre de cheval
de troie on lui fait croire qu'on est
d'accord pour le mariage on la met en
confiance et en l'amène à annuler
d'elle-même c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit je t'ai pas entendu parler de cheval
de troie
maman papa voici que des
hommes soit sieste ou pas home soit
sieste ou mais en soit si has to b
ça c'est pour faire passer pour un naze
qui n'a pas besoin de moi pour ça
monsieur et madame cotonne bienvenue
dans mon pays et bientôt chez moi madame
cotone c'est sa mère tu peux m'appeler
d'aujourd'hui comme vous voulez georgia
oui moi ça me va monsieur côté
georgia je peut vous emmener si vous
voulez un alonso
à tout à l'heure
il est super
mais s'il l'a fait tomber
on y va
oui quand leur couple et devant
l'assemblée le porteur remet deux
alliances qui ont été bénis par le gao
chapeau pour qu'ils les échanges mais
s'il n'y a pas des changes sa foi en
l'air le bon moment au bon endroit pour
aller c'est ce que j'allais tu me tues
l'a pas dit c'est mon idée ok le porter
c'est la cousine de guider
[Musique]
pourquoi moi les affaires délicates
c'était ton rôle mon rôle c'était de
sortir les poubelles atteindre les
étagères trop haute à ses hôtes que ça
et la flatterie ça ne marche pas or tu
vas t'y connais toute manière pourquoi
parce que c'est ton idée
mais dieu vous bénisse at il jamais pire
pourraient nous envier
tu veux on peut avoir un truc qu'il soit
un peu plus de leur génération avec un
garde sont repartis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
secours
lens
[Musique]
mais d'une force ambiance ria raymond
lonné stéroïdes c'est grave